Jesse Smollett is still refusing to
admit that he staged a hate crime attack
and now his brother is going even
further claiming that the disgraced
actor is really an assault victim who's
been falsely accused by police of making
it up smell its brother also saying
quote Jesse is as strong as iron but
following an attack like this there is a
normal and natural amount of post-trauma
that mostly anyone should expect to
suffer I've literally seen him violently
awakening from night terrors following
the assault some of my siblings as well
as Jesse's partner and closest friends
have seen similar things so what struck
me about this in addition to just that
ludicrous aspect of it was the fact that
if they're trying to start creating a
paper trail right now of there being a
physical manifestation of damages if
they're laying the groundwork for some
type of lawsuit by Jesse Smollett
against the city of Chicago I just hope
that they're not but what do you think
you'd have to have a tremendous number
of people involved in this frame-up like
a ten thousand people and as someone who
actually does experience night terrors
otherwise known as hypnagogic nightmares
I experienced them without ever
perpetrating a massive hoax which
embarrass your family your co-workers
people who defended you so I could say
go screw yourself he has ran up his
victim debt card you know everybody's
got a little victim debt card
he ran up as he wants more Vicky wants
to get he wants to get an extension on
his victim card you're not getting any
more victim from me but he wants Warren
to forgive this Ted I've had by the way
night terrors are yeah they're bad I
have ADD them turn like a normal
terrible night usually sleep paralysis
sleep paralysis you feel like you're
awake oh my god you know can I I'm gonna
see your sixteen Candles analogy another
wedding crashers night tears that's what
that little freaky son Todd had remember
that cystic weirdo they wanted to play
Tommy sticks with Vince more people feel
bad
people laugh at you don't make 90 tears
is when you come home from Iraq and
Afghan
to make an analogy before Smollett is
the media they both perpetuated a hoax
they both got caught and instead of
being contrite they're doubling down on
the hoax
these guys just need to lay low they
need to stop having their team write
op-eds and wait'll the thing blows over
patient
I love how isn't this the brother that
Jesse Smollett pretended to be when he
was pulled over okay thank you
also Kym Fox 2x yes she is the one who
said in the text message that we was
revealed last week that he's a liar she
says in the text message he lied to the
cops and also I would say to the brother
that when you the next time you think
your brother's having a night terror and
that you're witnessing it he's an actor
[Laughter]
what do you think I think it's so
natural for a brother to stand up for
another brother yeah you know I mean
it's his brother and he's you know he
felt that he should stand up and say you
know what give my brother the benefit of
the doubt and that's the way I really
looked at yeah yeah do you think he
believes it or do you think he's just
standing up for him
oh no well first of all I don't know cuz
I'm not in his head but I think that
Jesse Smollett continues to say that it
happened as he says now obviously the
Chicago Police don't feel that way even
Charles Barkley doesn't feel that says
but but I'm just saying to you Jesse
Smollett hasn't changed the police the
prosecution despite but he's not facing
charges and so at some point you guys
think hey why is the system why is the
government continuing to pursue a man
who really has been charged with nothing
they had their investigation no charges
a if we're talking about Trump yeah but
there was a mistake
[Laughter]